okay Steven what are you most excited
about to do after you leave here so go
on a date with you Quinn
[Music]
honestly I feel like I'm too attractive
for Seattle okay Loki
if I light up her head you reject
yourself I'm Jessica nice to meet you
Hello nice to meet you
like a fruit snack
no wait what's your name
I already said it you forgot I forgot
smoke is it short for something yeah
you're Muslim
your Muslim
this [__] said Muhammad three
times
Muhammad appeared in the mirror you
understand what I'm saying and she asked
are you must what's your name Ahmed
Muhammad are you Muslim no my last name
is James III a Christian
you're a Muslim I'm like the worst
mother you drink Duty you're not
supposed to do that hey okay they're hot
on police oh you're Muslim let me expose
you right now how do you feel about that
shade on alcohol yeah
yeah what about that bomb ass
pre-marital [__] yay
[Applause]
yay low-key you know when you've been
drinking and you wake up the next
morning
what about that shape owns bacon yeah
all aboard the Haram train okay she
exposed him around the train what's your
vision like because I'm waiting for my
kids I'm on 20 20 so I'm like
I'm like minus two points
why did you reject yourself I'm like a
family man like I really care about my
future with my family I've been thinking
about that since I was a kid I'm a
family [__] I'm a family [__]
what do you mean I'm a family [__]
yeah yeah I know but we already have
disagreements you said you want your
kids to have 20 20 Vision I'm like okay
don't have 20 20.
exactly that's what I was looking like
it's not going to work and you didn't
take my fruit snack that's kind of crazy
uh I'm not gonna lie it's kind of weird
to just offer candy to people you don't
know I wouldn't accept that [__] yeah
kind of like makes me think like would
you lace that [__] with why are you just
running up on me with candy you weirdo
he said she don't want no kids without
20 20 Vision imagine a kid's born you
got glasses he black [__] failure
look at this [__] spectacles little
ass [__] walking around with binoculars
on your eyes all the time so what brings
you here honestly I feel like I'm too
attractive for Seattle okay Loki
girl if you don't get the [__] up out of
here not too much but like objectively
I'm putting it in like the men in
Seattle uh-huh a lot of tech Bros and
there's just something about the
confidence of a [__] 22 year old
that's just very special why would you
date a young boy what's the problem it's
like this
this girl really thinks she's the main
character coming to find out she's not
even an NPC she's a mob this is the kind
of person you farm for XP I turned 24 in
March 15th what sign is that it's a
Pisces what about you when's your
Paradise oh cool I really like astronomy
stuff I've been that's something new
teach me something like I don't I'm not
that good at astronomy but like I'm
getting better at it no you're not
because you called it astronomy this
this
okay there's a bunch of people studying
Stars right now like please don't let us
in with that Voodoo mumbo jumbo [__]
okay if that makes sense I feel like I
love Australia hose they're super cool
so if you could be that a solo what I
have to ride that [__] back hoes
[Music]
foreign
this is my kingdom you were peasant you
need to buzz yourself out thank you
that's what that's I just want to
appreciate everyone's like wouldn't this
show be so much better if they could
Buzz himself out come to find out
they're still gonna find a way to get
the person they want buzzed out buzzed
out
okay okay you can leave this oh I can
lead this okay hey you know what I
thought she said you could leave this I
was like yeah oh my God that's what I
thought I heard look at her defensive
ass yeah she's not gonna be like prove
yourself to me oh I can leave this okay
what do you do
um I'm getting underpaid at non-profits
I'm in my like save the world phase and
applying to law school right now oh [__]
that's super exciting I'm so happy for
you applications are due today
so so Jessica I'm gonna light up red and
what I do you can project yourself and
you're free to go home and work on that
application
are you two really feeling each other uh
I don't I don't really think so
[Music]
okay you can spend my time here you I'm
super chill though oh yeah that's fair
if my man said nah I'm good
hey shots to you man he's like I don't
think you really want to go out with me
huh yeah yeah I'm gonna pass
yourself yeah you don't want to walk out
with an L you don't want to walk out
with the hell that's that's all it was
legs type is someone who is emotionally
open now try to be emotionally open yeah
nice a healthy emotional person then
it's just funny I like somebody's
emotionally open
good that's good tell me more about
yourself I'd like someone who's
emotionally open
it's nice no I I think therapy is a bare
minimum I'm trying to be I'm going to
school to be a therapist oh really
that's exciting
whether the dentist is this date going
well
I mean I really like talking to you no
yeah it's a very close conversation yeah
I think it's going well yeah I I don't I
see like very you're like very like
um Hello friends all my old friends hey
man I'm so glad we meet again that's
actually a pretty good talk yeah
very good friends I get that vibe from
everyone yeah
a fun fact about Ashley she loves Jesus
I do too really I honestly there is
nothing better than a good smoke Buddha
a what smoked gouda what's that cheese
is that not what you said I love Jesus
not cheese
[Music]
oh
the son the father and the children and
the mozzarella I swear to God the next
time some girl tells me she loves Jesus
I'm like I like cheese cheese too
I said Jesus I'm gonna reject myself I'm
disappeared okay but it was really nice
meeting oh my gosh
I'm good is that Ashley nice to meet you
you remember me right
what the [__] happening I don't know
that's weird I hope they got history
because if not yes
same way when you go to the pharmacy and
then you go you see your girl pick pick
like pick something from the bottom
shelf and then you smack her ass and she
turns around and it's not your girl yeah
yeah that's awkward sorry no no no
and all them
yeah I was like trying to go after you
and her sister
that's a character right there my man
looks like walking dick cheeks yeah he's
everything about him seems slimy
okay is everything okay you came in and
kissed her are you comfortable Ashley do
you two really know each other yeah we
do it's unfortunately
if you try to kiss her you can't go
unfortunately right after that you after
you kiss the bruh I like how the button
people behind the camera we're like yo
yeah yeah
I haven't
like what Junior High School yeah
we're about to rekindle the relationship
that was never there I don't know about
that
so what are you up to right now I'm a
grad student at UW right now
engineering no no no medical no law no
so you're wasting your time I'm sorry
I'm getting a degree in a Collegiate
athletic leadership ah
foreign
I think this might have been the most
rightful Buzz of the evening you know
you know some people think like being an
[__] is the only way to talk to him
in order to get their affection and this
guy's taking that to the oath degree oh
yeah
everyone unfortunately
we have not been together why are you
saying it like that
okay so you two know each other how well
I'm sorry I'm just famous in Seattle no
that's not exactly
unless you press the button
oh yeah how do you know Stephen A guy
that I have talked to in the past we
were just out on a date and we saw
Stephen just out at the bars he was
working my corner as I usually do
everything about this guy gives off
Shady like low-level drug dealer Vibe
like the kind of Dude to be like hey do
you want Coke on my penis to someone
he's never talked to before that's it so
the fact that she said she was on a date
with another dude and they saw this guy
the only reason you take note is if he's
trying to sell you something
was being super off like he is right now
like that's the kind of guy that in a
mafia movie he gets bought first
he sure was working the corner
I have a fun fact about Chloe she once
had a drink with O.J Simpson OJ Simpson
well you're still alive so I mean yes
yeah
guys hi guys hi hey this guy's so
dislikable women are just like can I
abort this missionary yeah
I understand though I'm Stephen
commissioner Quinn Quinn oh very nice to
meet you you have a very feminine
handshake I appreciate that thank you
you do too
[Laughter]
I got really soft hands that's just it
is what it is every time I shake a gross
head she was like oh what moisturizer
and then I gotta tell her it's genetics
I'll never be able to get like listening
ever have a girl rub your back and be
like
a baby's butt
that's my life
and that's why today's video is brought
to you by Thug
Chase early man living like some man
with a soft skin I'm not gonna lie they
do they do ain't nobody trying to have
that like dry ass crocodile skin yo
people really underestimate soft skin yo
yo they underestimate that stuff
like look at my hand like this is a
thick ass hand okay for Steven's red
flags are people have Daddy Issues do
you have Daddy Issues no me and my
daughter like this hey Dad absolutely
that's amazing okay Stephen what are you
most excited about to do after you leave
here so go on a date with you Quinn
best time
you know the type of guy to just
grabbing cigar stop puffing and choking
right away it's funny how the girl
before were like I'm not busting myself
out because I'm not taking this out uh
and all these girls with this guy are
like oh please help please and please I
suspect they're probably talking
backstage but yeah
some girls talk unfortunately guys yeah
guys saw two but not like girls yeah
what you mean I'm going on a date with
you later man why you ask me where I'm
going yeah what do I see when I think
about my future a future with you knock
knock who's there us
foreign
[Music]